4.4 million US workers filed for
unemployment last week pushing the
country's unofficial jobless rate to
nearly 13 percent it's more evidence the
kovat 19 pandemic has damaged the US
economy Congress is voting this week to
spend another half trillion dollars to
help small businesses and hospitals but
when it comes to helping state
governments reeling from the loss of
business and personal tax revenues the
Republican leader of the US Senate says
that's not going to happen
yeah I would certainly be in favor of
allowing States to use the bankruptcy
route it's saved some cities and there's
no good reason for it not to be
available my guess is their first choice
would be for the federal government to
borrow money from future generations to
send it down to them now so they don't
have to do that that's not something I'm
going to be the governor of New York
State who is a Democrat called Mitch
McConnell's comment outrageous yes
airlines are important yes more business
is important so police and fire and
health care workers who are the
frontline workers and when you don't
fund the state then the state can't fund
those services fictional sense to me
what's more New York's economy is the
third largest in the US and in the top
15 worldwide which means its survival as
a financial and cultural center is key
and US President Donald Trump's decision
to suspend immigration for 60 days on
economic grounds could hurt the US as
ties with other countries Indian
officials are closely studying the order
since hundreds of thousands of their
citizens many who work for US firms
could be affected all that matters
though - Connie Boyd in North Carolina
is her own economic future say when we
want to go back to it we don't know if
it's gonna be this year next year name
is specified is that job they just don't
know the only certainty
right now the economic pain is worsening
Rosalind Jordan al-jazeera